- I found this funny.
I didn't know that y'all were dating,
and then I found out that
you actually passed notes.
This is your thing, like, which I think
is kind of incredible and
so super cute high school.
But you passed notes
like during, like on set.
- Yeah.
- Not just to you, like, you pass notes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I was doodling one day
in my little academy notebook.
- [Kelly] You just slide it in?
You're just like...
- [Rachel] There you go.
- So Rachel, as you can see, she...
- [Rachel] I think it's
something cute, and then...
- [Kelly] You're like, aw.
- [Rachel] Something silly.
- She told me to draw her as a flower.
So, you know, I did this really
crude drawing of this flower
with a little smiley
face on it and some legs,
and like, just handed it to her.
But you know what, I'm glad
that that became such a story,
'cause afterwards, I got
kind of into drawing.
I feel like I got a lot better.
- He's really harnessed his ability.
- Yeah, and I actually made you something.
- [Kelly] What?
- Earlier, yeah, yes.
I found out that your
favorite animal is a dog.
You really like dogs, right?
- I love dogs, yeah.
- So in the same vein of this,
I decided to draw you as a dog.
- Did you draw me as a dog?
- Yeah, it's amazing.
He's so talented.
- So this is kind of...
- [Kelly] Make sure you show.
(audience laughing)
- Like, you're such a great team.
She set that up so well.
I was like, okay.
- So, but there's a lot
of nuance to this drawing,
as you see also because you're a singer,
so that your barking, there's a little...
- It's in a musical note.
- Kelly, you know the
really scary part of this?
The really scary part is
this is after he got better.
- [Kelly] This is after he got better.